welcome back to las vegas now mother's
day is around the corner and lifestyle
expert samantha vickers is here with
some ideas on how you can say thank you
thoughtfully yes not just saying thank
you you know you gotta give her
something that's right and you know what
lots for everybody but the first thing i
brought is leq so this is different
because this is what i saw on the on the
video yeah yes so this is the sidekick
for healthier and happier aging so it
actually is a
care companion device that was made for
65 and up okay so for grandmas or senior
moms this is what you want to give them
it's different from other devices
because it's proactive it's actually to
ask them you know hey you haven't called
your grandkids in a while why don't you
give them a call wow you know things
like that checking up on their health
yeah absolutely that's very cool yeah so
you can go to leq.com to check that out
and i have to tell you that with a
monthly subscription of 29.99 after an
initial one-time fee of the 249.99 it's
really a great value for taking care of
those aging parents in our lives yeah
absolutely absolutely that's really cool
i love that so next up let's give mom a
night off of cooking dinner i'm down
because the kids can eat it too and it's
perfect yes yes yes
this is milton's craft baker's thin and
crispy cauliflower crust pizza
it is have you ever tried these before
no but i love cauliflower crust okay so
i get it cauliflower crust pizza i tried
it out on my kids i tested out and i
didn't tell them that that's what it was
and i just gave it to them to try and
they were like mom this is so good and
they're like you should get that again
i'm all oh do you know that that's
cauliflower crust pizza they're like we
don't care we love it so it's so yummy
and you can pick it up at our local
sprouts perfect and give mom the night
off and actually have it be something
that she's going to like so yeah right
that's so great that's great the whole
fam yeah moving on we've got about a
minute left okay so i had to include
paige and wright this is a local
boutique and i absolutely love it
because yes look at all the cute unique
things she has so not only is it a local
boutique but everything in her store is
local artisans or local small businesses
so you can feel good shopping with them
and what i love is that she's actually
giving all of the viewers a 15 discount
yeah so all you have to do is use las
vegas now at check out on page and write
and you can shop everything get 15 off
incredible incredible okay let's get to
the apron because this is so so special
so sweet okay this is really really easy
a really you know just a heartwarming
gift for mom so you just use some
acrylic paint painted on the palms of
those kiddos hands and have them put it
on the apron they can sign it you could
do this on a canvas bag you know for mom
grandma any of those any of those loved
ones in your life diy always makes it
just a little more special right yeah
yeah it definitely does sam you are
great thank you and happy mother's day
in advance to you thank you so much
thank you j.c i'll send it to you
all right thank you rocky football fans